But the key distinction here,
he mentioned Rippa, which is resource at
the bottom layer.
Then you extend that with infrastructure
to make whatever that resources are wild
and they're not constrained or
controlled. That's the key defining
feature of a resource. There's no
operator, there's no owner of a
resource. Not not
It's kind of like there's no owner of
the laws of physics, but there is an
owner of that house over there, which is
built
based on the prin- the prin- the
physical laws allowed that the stuff
that makes that house up to emerge in
the universe. We've organized it into a
house now.
There's an owner of that house, but
nobody owns the laws of physics. That's
kind of
the the concept of like the resource
layer at the very base. Infrastructure
is a thing that you build on top or of
or out of that to extend it in a useful
way. There are operators of that. There
are potentially owners of that.
When you get into platforms, now you're
making things more useful that
you know, you you don't just have
lumber, you have machine systems and
transfer systems and things that are you
can build on top of now. And an
application is is the specific use that
is narrowly focused on solving a problem
that a real person actually has.